millions of people around the globe have
joined the call for change by
participating in blackout Tuesday and
last night Jimmy Fallon made an
emotional apology as he returned to the
Tonight Show after a week-long break I'm
not gonna have a normal show tonight I'm
gonna have a different kind of show I'm
not a racist I don't feel this way
Fallon addressed the ongoing protests
amid his own controversy this SNL skit
from 2000 that recently resurfaced in it
the then cast member is in blackface
impersonating Chris Rock there was swift
backlash and calls for his show to be
canceled I can't not say I'm horrified
and I'm sorry and I'm embarrassed what
it kept getting advised was to just stay
quiet and to not say anything and I
realized that the silence is the biggest
crime that white guys like me and the
rest of us are doing staying silent and
we need to stop saying that's not okay
more than just one day on Twitter Fallon
said it was time to get educated and
discussed the controversy with the
n-double a-c-p s Derrick Johnson and
CNN's Don Lemon that was really honest a
very brave of you Jimmy's not the only
one speaking out I am so sad and I am so
angry what you see now is Jane Fonda
pink Billy
Eilish John Stamos Michael Jordan
everybody's coming together and saying
we cannot stand so I believe this is not
just a moment it's a movement and
watching that man die slow left the hole
he cried for his mama as the murder
unfold LL Cool J shared this emotional
video honoring George Floyd with a
freestyle rap harassed by cops word - my
ancestor souls and tomorrow on the talk
Eve talks about how the protests are
impacting her marriage to Maximilian
Cooper I am in an interracial
relationship I am having some of the
most difficult and uncomfortable
conversations I think I've ever had and
vice-versa with my husband but at the
same time it's a beautiful thing he
wants to understand
that's what the nation that's what the
world has to do it's not gonna be easy
but we all have to be comfortable with
the idea of being uncomfortable and it's
gonna take a lot to find a solution but
I do think that there are millions and
millions of people who are willing to do
it we're not just trying to entertain
we're trying to empower and educate we
don't want you to be allies we want you
to be our brothers and sisters in the
struggle and I love the fact that
everybody's coming on board and look at
this et's corporate parent Viacom CBS
honored George Floyd with this powerful
eight minute and 46 second blackout
video symbolizing the length of time
that Floyd was suffocated by a police
officer the video aired at 5:00 p.m.
yesterday on Viacom CBS channels
including BT CBS Sports vh1 and MTV the
first time in our business I'm seeing
companies throw caution to the wind and
say this is not right let's get on the
side of right and raise our voices for
common sense another way stars are
showing support is on Instagram posting
a blank black image and using the
hashtag blackout Tuesday by putting a
pause on sharing other images the
silence is being used to amplify the
voices and message of the black lives
matter movement
everyone is using their platform
everybody is using what they can their
medium to do what they can do
[Music]